well let's let's talk about a cause for
hope because the one thing that breaks
all of this is independent media and we
got this story from the independent jon
stewart sides with joe rogan as more
artists leave spotify this overreaction
is a mistake neil young joni mitchell
blah blah blah then crosby stills and
nash then uh roxanne gay i believe her
name is she's pulling her her podcast i
don't know what her podcast is but she
does have 800 some thousand followers on
twitter so she it's probably not nothing
but check this out in what may be the
weirdest turn in the joe rogan story
mike.com reports brazil's far-right
president is thirsty for joe rogan on
main
excellent headline mike
really really desperate but uh we get
your point
bolsonaro tweeted i'm not sure what joe
rogan thinks about me or my government
but it doesn't matter if freedom of
speech means anything it means that
people should be free to say what they
think no matter if they agree or
disagree with us stand your ground hugs
from brazil we also have el salvador
what is this
oh my gosh
sarcasm oh this is the president of el
salvador making a comment specifically
saying um you know you know what what
can't sarcasm freedom of the press is
under attack in el salvador but he did
the the spongebob
sarcasm yeah right
joe rogan
joe yeah the controversy around you has
reached international incident
proportions
i thought this was over we talked about
it it's been like a month now
um i'm honestly i was kind of like okay
okay where are we doing this but let's
just i i just
how
what's going on man
you see the video of uh jill holding his
hand and walking him and he's like
fumbling around like confused our
president's lost his mind he's deploying
troops we've got
the fear factor guy is the most
influential media personality in the
world
this is it just it's just it's quite
well the narrative crumbles under truth
and they can't have people speaking the
truth because when they do it literally
obliterates everything that they're
trying to accomplish which they would
never be able to do if people were in
the dark and they were ignorant so they
have to shut people down and there has
been a consorted multinational corporate
effort to shut down joe rogan the white
house has been making statements saying
that they need to do more to fight
misinformation
pretty much
you know alluding to the fact that they
need to censor joe rogan so when you
have pressure from the us government
when you have pressure from the esg you
know environmental social governance
credit score when you have major banks
and investment firms coming to you
saying hey get rid of him take him out
we got to censor him that's a lot of
pressure but we're and and but it also
stands true to the important messages
that he releases yeah i'm loving this
because
i'm pretty sure all of this
has increased joe rogan's influence oh
yeah
tremendously a full order of magnitude
or more yes now there's something i want
to point out about this uh this story so
firstly i want to mention this jon
stewart he made a lot of the right
noises he mentioned that this is an
overreaction unfortunately he ends up
saying something along the lines of
you know the real problem is that the
algorithms are promoting misinformation
which is kind of what we hear from
left-wing people who want to censor this
type of thing but i i think that he
might just be misled there stewart does
not come come across as the kind of guy
who wants the censor one thing i wanted
to point out though tim at the end of
the article on the independent about
this we have a little blurb that uh a
misinformation a misinformation
researcher called the warning labels on
his podcasts
too little too late you know who that
misinformation researcher is
abby richards
the conspiracy theory pyramid so so
sheamus made one of one of your best uh
works
he analyzed abby richards conspiracy
theory pyramid and she actually is it's
the most insane thing i've ever seen
this woman who's considered an expert
question questions the iran contra
scandal like that's not we know that
happened well she and so what she said
yeah exactly so what she said in
response that was oh well like i'm
questioning reagan's involvement but
the point is kind of moot because she's
had to remake her conspiracy theory
hierarchy pyramid scale more than once
because things on it literally turned
out to be true so she had to remove them
yeah i want to make this point for luke
while luke is here
she makes this pyramid where on the it's
like small on the bottom it gets bigger
on the top and as you get higher up it
all of a sudden is like anti-semitic
conspiracy theory alert and it's like
hollow earth but one of the things she
had on one of her original pyramids was
bill gates microchipping people
and she had to remove it
because bill gates is developing birth
control microchips for people there you
go luke um take it out she had covered
lab leak under uh she got rid of her c3s
as well she had to get rid of that there
was another one i'm not sure if it would
be too obscene to mention on air but
there was another one she mentioned
where the with the hollow earth use the
lord of the rings yes no that's right
and then it's funny because she took the
words deep state as a conspiracy theory
and she put them in his own she calls
the anti-semitic point of no return but
then lower down on the pyramid someone
pointed out
she has fbi spied on mlk
it's like wait so do you love having a
deep state or not it she she calls the
like if you believe in hollow earth
you're an anti-semite yeah which is
crazy if you believe in a deep state but
then you made a really funny point in
saying that
she's the conspiracy theorist accusing
all of these conspiracies
yes exactly she calls them all jewish
and she also says they're all connected
so like believing the deep state is like
connected to believing in hollow earth
and like all this these absurd tenuous
connections so go watch the video if you
can bring it all together called leftist
meme reviews like the opposite of alex
jones yeah yeah no no no
well yeah but to bring it all together
this is someone being quoted in the
mains in a mainstream news source and a
corporate corporate press
about accusing joe rogan of being
misinformation and she had to remake her
conspiracy chart because she got it
wrong so much she literally said
multiple things were called conspiracy
theories that were too dangerous to
believe on her chart that literally
turned out to be true so she had to
remove them from from updates i'm having
a good time look at this i got this
story this spotify ceo is defending joe
rogan again
saying that there will be opinions and
beliefs that we disagree with but
they're not in the business of dictating
discourse i want to give a special shout
out to joe
because he's done something tremendous
for all of us
by being on spotify unity did he
basically just built a 30-foot beautiful
concrete wall from sea to shining sea
yes
because what happens now is spotify made
they staked a claim on his show they say
we need this to make money we want this
show
the more joe has on controversial
figures the more we on our podcasts are
able to have on controversial figures as
well because when they the ceo coming
out now and saying well there's going to
be people we disagree with
yep because they can't ban joe so joe
becomes the the baseline for what is
basically allowed and if joe's going to
talk to robert malone and peter
mccullough everyone else can too yeah
this is they still might hold a double
standard mind you but it sets that limit
we don't need his permission though we
can do it we can pioneer it as well it's
not about his permission it's about
spotify is now in in the position of
being like
but if we ban them people are going to
come at us about rogan and we don't want
to lose that money so just do stop stop
he's pushing the overton window with
what is acceptable to even be talked
about and when he's talking to mainline
medical professionals that big tech
social media companies censor like
people who are credited people who are
in the field of mrna vaccines people who
literally helped develop them he's
bringing information and knowledge that
is becoming sacred but he's making it
mainstream he's absolutely obliterating
the official narrative just by simply
questioning it he's not making
statements he's talking to individuals
from both sides he's not just
interviewing conspiracy theorists or
crazies or or people who are on the
french he's also interviewing sanjay
gupta of all people there's no way to
attack this individual so they literally
make stuff up out of nowhere
and they're trying to destroy him not
even on any significant charges they
don't have anything what do they have on
them the only way
for the left to win is through
authoritarianism
and i'll be i'll be real i've talked
about it before when you look at the
political compass you're talking about
economic left and like uh libertarian so
left libertarians it is life on hard
mode this idea that you're going to
convince everyone to cooperate and agree
outside of capital is is is almost a
pipe dream i think it's fantastic but
only works at really small scales so as
the left starts gaining more and more
power the only way to convert people
because they're going to fundamentally
disagree with you is through force so
they ban people they censor you look at
all these countries that's that's how
they have to pull it off they smeared
bolsonaro so hard i thought this guy was
like a lunatic for the last couple years
when i've just the media has been
talking about this far right
authoritarian brazilian guy and i'm like
okay here we go we got another hard line
nazi in power but it turns out this guy
supports american free speech and is
going to speak up for joe rogan
well john stewart made a good point he
said you know instead of just trying to
cancel someone debate that person he
didn't say it exactly like that but he
said counter their points what points
are they countering that joe rogan has
made what arguments are they going
against the points they can't exactly
saw sanjay try
yeah well sanjay was forced to admit he
was lying you know what's really funny
you take sanjay out of his protective
bubble and all of a sudden he is like
yeah it was not true shouldn't have said
that we shouldn't have said that he was
a bumbling buffoon and then went on cnn
the next day and said and contradicted
himself which is crazy and said oh yeah
i i didn't mean that it's kind of
hilarious though it's like everyone
could see both what was he thinking
like
talk smack about somebody to their face
or i'm sorry behind their back like on
air yeah yeah you're not behind their
back when you're on air
well you're on cnn you don't get that
many viewers now let's be fair he kind
of had faith no one would see it the
only way the left is able to maintain
any kind of narrative is through
sophistry yeah manipulating withholding
information
censoring shutting people down i think
if cnn and msnbc went out of business
tomorrow like just disappeared things
the world would change dramatically i i
don't i don't know if i agree really
yeah somebody would reply some it would
be young turks or something like that
and to be honest their ratings are so so
far down in the gutter so you think you
can't i guess erasing the the channel is
different than erasing the methodology
you think the methodology is just going
to perpetuate oh yeah
yeah you look you're always going to
have people who are willing to lie for
money and you're always going to have
people with a set political agenda who
are okay misleading the public and mad i
was gone anyway
she's she's she's her show is changing i
guess like once a week and then she's
she's out for two weeks so she's
basically just like
you know she's she's cashed out as much
as he could ripping off these people i
love i love how these people go on
twitter and they're like they're all
right-wing grifters
it's like yo
rachel maddow and brian selter and don
lemon and chris cuomo like cuomo
literally pretended he was under
quarantine you guys are getting ripped
off like crazy it's it's sad man it is
but i wonder how many of those people
like they know it and they're just
enforcers for these evil people right
like they're not
how many how many of these people who
are supporting them
actually believe it or no it's a lie but
are in on it and helping yeah i think
there's a big proportion of it that's
evil i think that there's a reason some
of them get caught doing spirit cooking
and all the horrible things i think it
gets even far worse or far deeper than
we could even imagine i think we're only
scratching the surface with just how bad
some of these people are and then on the
other half there are some dumb people
who are just following along and
repeating the things just to be accepted
as in yeah i think there's also a third
group here which is
people who genuinely believe in the
cause and they do this very dangerous
thing which is rationalized telling lies
in order to get their agenda across
people will convince themselves that it
isn't wrong to lie about something if
they think the greater good will come
about through telling that lie and i
think that's true in a very large
majority of cases when it comes to these
news reporters because they're saying
things that at some point they have to
know aren't true
so and i think they're able to
rationalize that by saying i'm one of
the good guys what i want for the world
is better than what these republicans
want for the world and they're willing
to lie to get it so why don't i do the
same you need a lot of drugs to be in
that state to be honest with you and i
highly doubt there's a lot of them but i
know i i know i think it's actually very
common they're children
they have a children's view they view
the world digitally like we're at point
a and we'd like to get to point c and
that means point b is going to be brutal
dictatorship the point c is beautiful
they believe the ends justify the means
because they have the mentality of
toddlers but the danger is because they
don't they don't realize
that you never meet the end if your end
goal was the extermination of all
humanity okay well then i understand
you'd say the ends justify the means
because we're gonna get to the end in
about five years if we enact this policy
but if you're if your goal is we want to
create a socialist utopia and we're
willing to wipe out you know people to
get it then how do you defend your new
utopia from the next revolution it's the
same tired story there is no end you
there's maintenance after you achieve
your goal and maintenance using those
strategies is just despotism
authoritarianism dictatorship fascism
etc i saw a friend of mine from
one of my best friends from childhood we
were having an adult conversation in our
30s this is like three or four years ago
after trump got elected and he was like
we need to use their tactics against
them that's fascist we need to use i
don't know if he was saying street
violence um coercion he was like we will
you whatever and i thought said you have
to understand you're becoming the demon
that you want to destroy if you're doing
that it's the
the process is the destiny i'm trying to
explain and it was so disturbing to hear
an adult that i have trusted my entire
life say these things to me after we've
been through it together and talked
about how you can't use
the evil
methodology to defeat evil it's
impossible but but still he's
brainwashed well yeah but i would say
it's even worse than that ian you said
it it's sort of like trying to
become the beast to defeat the beast but
when he's saying we need to use street
violence against these trump supporters
we need to use their tactics against
them what street violence is he talking
about i think it was the proud boy's
auntie [ __ ] kerfuffle but the proud boys
weren't starting those fights it's all
whatever the media made them think i
didn't ask exactly so what happens is
oftentimes a person will think i'm
fighting fire with fire when they were
just propagandized to think the other
side was using fire in the first place
so they're just attacking innocent
people that's exactly what it is the far
left goes out and says we're defending
ourselves as they burn down small
businesses it is it is psychotic and
they believe the ends justify the means
they're like well if we burn down these
buildings then in one year we'll have a
utopia it's like yo that's not gonna
happen because the guy who's who's
building you burned down he's gonna come
back with his own group of people
protesting against you for being violent
psychopaths yeah and the children of the
people getting bombed in the middle east
are going to remember that their entire
life there's a great song
about this that i heard it's called will
of the people it's by uh tim castle oh
yeah yeah and it shows the cycle of
timothy
the cycle never ends it only begins
again that's right so at the end of the
of the song that like one of the uh well
i don't well you probably might have
probably already seen it's called wild
people people are pulling down the
statue but every time they pull it down
it just rotates and another one comes up
not my idea that was a piece of artwork
based on on the arab spring that every
time they pull one statue of a dictator
down it just springs up the next one
that's what it is and these people don't
understand that there's always a cycle
of authoritarianism of violence that
that's why the best thing you can do is
build a system right now that respects
people's fundamental rights doesn't
engage in these tactics
and that's literally how you get your
utopia yeah when you have freedom you
have prosperity it's that simple when
you have governments controlling every
aspect of your existence destroying
capital and destroying the free flow of
it you have again the down aggression
and the the the downgrading of humanity
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time